معنا من عمان اللي وقفه زدواري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز ما الذي
يجري يعني
موسكو تتهم السلطات الاوكرانيه بانها شنت
هجوما على خمس مقاطعات في موازاتي هذا
الفيديو الذي تتداوله الاوساط الاوكرانيه
الفيديو دعائي الذي يشير الى الصمت والقول
انه لا يجوز الحديث
عن توقيت البدء ماذا يحصل
الجميع يتحدث عن الهجوم المضاد وفي
القراءات والتي تحدثنا بها قبل شهر كنا
نتوقع ان يبدا الهجوم اما في الاسبوع
الاول او في الاسبوع الثاني من هذا الشهر
من خلال المعطيات العامه لكن
استنادا الى البيان الروسي
الذي هو يتحدث عن بدء الهجوم لا اعتقد ان
ما جرى من عمليات هي البدايه الحقيقيه
للهجوم قد تكون نوع من الهجوم التظليل او
الهجوم التمهيدي الذي يساعد على نجاح
الهجوم الرئيسي لماذا اولا حجم القوه
المستخدمه خمسه كتائب مشاءليه مدعمه
بكتيفتي دبابات اي بمعنى
سته وستين دبابه حجم القوه المدرعه التي
اشترك استنادا الى معهد دراسات الحرب وصل
الى اوكرانيا حتى نهايه الشهر الماضي 500
دبابه فنحن نتحدث عن نسبه واحد الى سته او
اقل من حجم القوه التي وصلت والتي يتم
اعدادها لتمثيل الهجوم ثم
ان الهجوم الرئيسي
المنطق العسكري وطبيعه الجغرافيا والاهداف
تقول ان سيكون اتجاه الهجوم ليس في منطقه
دونست ليس باتجاه مارينكا انما سيكون
باتجاه
فولنافاخا
ميلوتوبل كجهد وجهد اخر باتجاهي ظلما فاقا
ويواصل التقدم باتجاه ماريوبل وصولا الى
بحر ازوف لقطع الطريق على القرن اذا ما
يجري الان قد اضعه في صوره عندما تم
الهجوم على خاركيف واستعاده السيطره على
94% من المناطق المحتله كان الاعلام يتحدث
عن هجوم في منطقه خرسون ولم ياتي على ذكر
منطقه خاركير الان الحديث عن
افديفيكا مارينكا بينما الهجوم حسب
القراءات وحسب المعطيات على الارض تقول
سيكون في الجزء الجنوبي من جبروجيا وفي
الجزء الشمالي الشرقي من خرسون وتكون
اهداف المرحله الاولى
والمرحله الثانيه حدود القرم ماريوبل
بالاشاره مره اخرى الى هذا الفيديو
الدعائي الذي يتحدث عن الصمت الى اي مدى
هذا الموضوع مهم في هذه المعركه والى اي
مدى تعتقد ان الاوكرانيين قادرون على
مفاجاه الجانب الروسي
يعني هذا الاشارات بالصمت هي تؤكد ما
تحدثت عنه ان وراء الاكمه ما وراءها وان
الجهد الرئيسي للهجوم لم يفصح عنه ولن
يفصح عنه حتى تبدا ساعات الصفر لاحظ الان
هذه الاشارات هي تدعم التوجه الذي تحدثت
عنه وعن معركه
خاركيف فيما كان الحديث يدور عن معركه
خرسون الان من حيث المفاجاه المفاجاه على
المستوى الاستراتيجي لم تعد موجوده عندما
نتحدث عن المفاجاه الاستراتيجيه كما في
حرب عامل 73 ان هناك هجوم او لا هجوم الان
الهجوم اصبح حتمي من حيث عمليه على الاقل
البعد التعليلي اذا اين المفاجاه المفاجاه
تكمن في المستوى العملياتي حجم القوه
اتجاهات القوه اهداف المرحله الاولى ساعه
الصفر هذا هو نوع المفاجاه العملياتيه
المفاجاه التكتيكيه لا يتسع المجال للحديث
عنها لانها تدخل في تفصيلات تفصيلات
المعارك اذا لم يعد هناك مفاجاه
استراتيجيه هناك مفاجاه عملياتيه اشاره
الصمت هي عنوان هذه المفاجاه شكرا لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان